CLARE ABSHIRE:
Are you in love?
I hope so.
But ask yourself this:
When it happened,
is any of it
anything like you planned?
HENRY DETAMBLE:
Is this person that now owns
a huge part of your life
anything like
you thought they'd be?
Did they arrive when
they were supposed to?
♪ (UPLIFTING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
HENRY: Sometimes when
I'm stressed, I time travel.
I can't control it.
If I make the mistake
of loving someone,
I don't know how many times
I'm going to have to lose them.
YOUNG HENRY: Mom!
-Is that gonna happen now?
-Maybe.
I'm trying to hold on.
-(HORNS HONK)
-(TIRES SCREECH)
Hey, hold on.
-(HORNS HONK, TIRES SCREECH)
-Jesus Christ!
So, how long
you been seeing Clare?
HENRY: From time to time.
I don't like him.
SPEAKER:
But he's important to Clare.
GOMEZ:
How is that even possible?
Woo!
INGRID: It'd be nice
if you at least appreciated him.
I've loved him
since I was six years old.
No, you loved him!
It's me, Clare.
I'm Henry, the same Henry.
Someday.
Why is Clare crying?
You can't change anything.
You couldn't even get married.
♪ (MUSIC CLIMAXES) ♪
CLARE: I miss you.
HENRY: I'm here now.